hello everybody my name is Barbara and
welcome back to 590 [__] boys do bar 3
time for shot number 3 I think I'm
starting this off a little too
energetically I'm not quite drunk yet so
it doesn't explain my rapid degradation
in behavior so once more unto the breach
my friends double in trouble under the
bubble and thank everyone for the great
time that you're about to have and screw
everyone that hates you
Catania da svidaniya oh ok
whoa whoa ok so what it is I just got
everyone better equipment I don't feel
like ah crap
come on I just started the game why does
it gotta open up with an ass beating you
know what I'm gonna [__] all of you up
cuz screw you I'm not gonna [__] you
guys up am i I'm gonna lose this alright
oh [__] Oh tits
tits I'm not oh [__] okay man I'm not
gonna win this mi [__] damn it god damn
it [__] a dog ah [__] I was all ready
for this has opened up in a terrible
fashion I should have I should have just
tried to run it'd probably be best if I
die now because he's [__] oh [__] god
damn it the second episode started so
good
this episode started so terribly but
[__] yourself wrong though oh I hope I
saved well alright looks like my toast
didn't work very well welcome to the
party everyone I guess Jesus got damn ok
I'm out there ok pop him in know above
it man that's illegal looking so what I
did is I farmed a little bit but not
much
I got everyone better equipment such
that it can deal with these guys capably
and have a little more defense so
there's one place that I have not been
which is the right vent and that's the
only other place on this map that I
haven't been I've been everywhere else I
have a feeling cuz if I recall the right
side is where toy bonnie what is that
about
the right side is where toy bonnie was
yep I was right I knew it I knew it
hey ha ha ha ha I was looking for me
yeah yeah baby I'm not touching your ass
oh well hey you're missing now man
ready please ready plane ready well
that's not much of a clue what am I
supposed to do about that
god dammit okay so what now I was right
about my guess but where am I gonna find
him I need a Lube do I need Lube I need
Lube don't I
I need Lube I'm gonna have to get Lube
our night god damn it I gotta get Lube
this is my gas but knowing this game and
its debauchery I'm just assuming crash
I'm pretty sure this could kill him but
okay all right we got this and
preferably if I fight these higher-level
ones I'm gonna be able to find a new
super item for the other guys now I have
a feeling there's a dragon dildo
somewhere in this game that people are
gonna be very upset Sally it's not like
the the game developer wouldn't have
something in relation to a dildo of
dragons much like the queen of dragons
needs her dragon dildo but who knows
these things and if I'm even making
sense anymore so there's got to be a
place where okay so if the sex toy thing
happened where I killed an enemy I can
only assume that it also is gonna be
where I can kill an enemy which means
that I need to farm level threes until I
get to where I need to be but also it's
got to take a lot of stuff now whatever
it'll farm me up some tokens so I might
as well she had this little - oh yeah I
forgot that a balloon boy is in there
but I don't think that's a balloon boy
that I need okay so well this is level 2
also okay where am I gonna find a little
3 oh it was I was already in the room
for level 3 I'm an idiot okay so if I
farm up level threes that means I'm
gonna [__] goddamn but so many of you
okay well no this kills you in one go
anyway so if I can just have skills
okay that's good that's good that's good
okay cool cool cool cool
hi this good this is good cool cool cool
so you're gonna scream indie you're
gonna wail on a god okay I need to get
back to the puppet I keep forgetting god
damn but why did I have to make the
puppet ruin my life uh I got this got
this got this gotta gotta gotta getta
getta gonna give you to go go go go come
on you big [__] don't kill me don't
don't
okay there we go good good good okay so
now that sound that was a lot of stuff
man okay so I don't know if I'm supposed
to just keep wailing on him like that
until I get what I need I mean that's
usually my strategy in these things but
honestly who knows
god damn and I'm so out of stuff god
that is like a lot maybe I can go back
to the UH
maybe we can go back to the the bathroom
maybe I'll be able to go down to the
like maybe it's okay maybe not okay so I
just gotta find a way to get more token
since I can get more items because holy
[__] this is getting expensive god damn
it get out of my whoa metal one
Wow
that was a lot of goodies no that was
good those good that was really cool
what okay
so wow that was like awesome don't give
me a lot of [__] - damn okay so that's
good okay that's really good
goddamn I'm still reeling from that like
holy [__] okay so now that I got that
stuff I'm actually doing pretty good
like really good okay all right cool
okay so now that that's the thing now I
can do what I need to do to be able to
get what I need which is far more the
level 3 crap and hopefully be able to
get what I need which is some Lube I
need a big ol hand of like Lube handy
blue I got I'm not making sense I've
only had three shots but they were big
shots they were goddamn big shots oh boy
[__] I'm not it's gonna be a fun
adventure you're gonna see by the end of
this one you didn't see in the last one
I got really lovely W in the last one
but this one is he's gonna be poor
lonely in hell my log roll or something
to that effect
goddamn why do you do attack first I
need them all to have special items I
need them to get the super items why do
they come in like pairs of like umpteen
but Jill oh hey again give me some
goodies there we go
that's awesome that's so much stuff
that's amazing
why does it give so much I want more of
the metal stream damn that's like really
cool is it like uh yeah my hair's not
cooperating with is that like a metal
streamer in like every single area
such that I can kill one in one area and
then it'll be good for the other I mean
there's like a metal steer there's like
a metal streamer in every room is that
what you're supposed to assume or is it
just gonna be like the very rare random
I don't know I'm not making that sense
salmon no special item no nothing that I
need maybe it's not what I need like
maybe I'm totally off base and I I don't
think I'm only operating under the
assumption that mangles thing was like a
voucher that I found for the previous
thing but I mean the best thing I can do
is farm this anyway because it's gonna
level me up and also it's gonna give me
the throw [__] oh [__] I wish there was
something I can attack multiple enemies
okay I gotta plan this out god dammit
chica you do nothing ma'am nice nice
that's very nice blam dead yeah very
nice ah nice God God okay I mean the
only good thing I consume that the more
of these things that I kill the better
chance I have to get what I need which
may be the ultimate item or maybe the
item to get what's-his-face unstuck but
either way she could just learn skills
so that's good I guess
don't do it well I need to keep it
together I need to actually think about
logical rational stuff so either way
what do you guys think about drunk
minecraft coming back I want you to
comment there like last week it was
really interesting because a lot of
people were assuming that I was just
drinking every day but what really
happened is I only drank two days out of
the last week but what it looked like
was that every day I was getting drunk
off my ass over and over again I think
in fact that was not the case at all
like absolutely not like I don't do that
I hardly drink as it is but I mean just
because videos were coming out every day
they looked really bad for me but that
wasn't a gator but I am really glad
because of like compounding on the idea
that like it was it was not only that
this happened which was just a whimsy
that I had because I don't drink much I
thought it'd be really fun you guys
loved it to death but also drunk
minecraft finally came back like one of
the original facets of this channel was
drunk migrant we've been doing drunk
minecraft for almost as long as the
channel has existed like the first time
that happened was when I did a birthday
livestream like right after I start my
channel only a few months after me and
Bob we got on live stream we got drunk
and it was awesome we had a lot of fun
and we just had played minecraft and it
was just like what just was and it was a
thing that we enjoyed and we did it for
the sake of enjoying it nothing else in
and like that idea still holds true to
this day and like that's amazing that it
still is a thing like holy hell we can
still do that and have fun and you guys
like I was reading the comments I was
just tickled to death that you guys were
just so so into it too because I for one
was very like I've been to the point
where it's just like we've been doing it
for so long I don't know how much longer
he could possibly go on for but you guys
it was so much fun to be able to do it
and we didn't have a plan for we didn't
have an idea of what we're gonna do it
was just kind of like okay it is so what
what else can we do about it it's like
this is what it is in Todd I and it was
just exactly that it was exactly what
we've always wanted to be which is just
total [__] but fun [__] like
that in it of itself is amazing and I'm
like I really want to know what you guys
think if drunk minecraft comes back
because there's a lot of people new to
the channel now
that I've never never seen drunk
minecraft earn don't know what it is I
don't know what the point of it is or
why it is what it is so just like you
know I want to know like because like I
mentioned this in the last time that was
playing this last time that I was going
through five nights to [__] boys and I
was talking about and getting all
emotional and weepy because I was really
drunk and whatnot but there's like the
heart and soul of the channel is the
fact that I'm able to put up whatever I
want to put up and have fun doing it and
like that's exactly what I've always
wanted to be able to do and the reason
why I do it and why I love what I do
because even if you're playing video
games for a living you'll find that like
like any other youtuber tell you like
over time like it wears on you no matter
what you do like if you eat work at your
favorite restaurant you won't like the
food there but I mean I've been able to
have so much fun for so long doing what
I do just because I've been able to stay
creative and stay you know interesting
to me it may not seem interesting new
because there's like 68 parts of drunk
minecraft and whatnot big long-running
series but like I'm able to do these
small things that are different like
this one I'm doing the five nights of
[__] boys it's different okay like also
I want to mention that I have no idea
what I'm doing and I don't know why I'm
not getting what I need but it's like
it's just a little bit different and
like so interesting to me because like
I'm just able to do it and people really
really watch it and there's no greater
honor than people like watching the
things that I do and like enjoying the
things that I make and the fact that I'm
able to do that as a whole is just
amazing whoa hey whoa hey whoa a stick
what the [__] is this [__]
okay cool [__] I can beat you I can beat
you down I'll beat you into a pulp
okay all right okay all right baby way
um what was the thing is it I can do
this stuff and I can have fun with this
and I can just enjoy real cupcakes all
right cool I was like it it took like no
time at all awesome
Hey look that for you like this is like
I'm able to do what I want to do and do
it with all the joy my heart and be able
to do it and love it love what I do
because you guys allow me to do it and
also because the things that I do you
guys don't think are [__] weird like
you guys are totally with it you look
you're weirdos like me and it's awesome
like the fact that that is a thing is
really cool like you guys may not be
able to understand that I understand
that you don't understand but like like
these small privileges that I have
little oilier racial privilege but you
know like what I'm talking about is like
these small little little joys in my
life that I'm able to do and know that
you know it may not be totally loved but
at least it'll be somewhat except at the
point where I'm able to do that mainly
you know listen that's the whole point
that's the whole point
god those shots were big at this point I
was earning to realize like those shots
were really big those were definitely is
these definitely double shots here I
whoa boy
I should have known when it was going in
my mouth that I was just like I've been
troubled now and that phrase that that
sounded wrong okay either way I got like
a I got like a no that's sex toy stick
complete this is completely useless and
you should probably throw it away as
soon as possible okay can I use it on
Bonnie maybe is that a thing I could do
okay I got to go through the area to get
to Bonnie I don't know if I'm gonna have
to fight Bonnie or something for problem
sure she god damn house like right there
alright fine [__] you I may be able to
get another cool item out of you okay ah
[__] I need to not waste time because
okay well now that now that uh now the
chica has our ultimate weapon there's
gonna be a lot ease
okay done she got caught there we go
okay good good good
okay we're dead cool cool now there gets
to I get to ultimate items is going very
well for me haha this episode did not
start out well but hey it's going very
well for me okay
so I still didn't get I'll need to like
come back and farm here for another
ultimate item because if it works like
the last one it's just like every single
one of these things damn it okay you
know I'm not gonna I'm not gonna bother
ready fine
I'm not touching your ass though okay
engage the state [__] oh I see
okay I need to save just get some bad
happens haha uh why does this bring me
such goddamnit okay good good good
watches bring me such joys what I'm
trying to say wait what oh hey I did it
okay I did it okay cool I should get out
of this area though because I'm about to
be [__] rekt okay so now that I got
that I'm gonna go back to the pub and
I'm gonna get uh what I need to do there
and I'm also gonna get toy Bonnie the
equipment to catch up to everybody else
and then then oh then shits gonna go
down like you wouldn't believe
it's weird having Mangal just being
Mangal and not toy foxes
I guess he wasn't ice hockey and then he
got to swear by the kitties no no no
popping mom that's illegal - the legal
popping man can give me some good stuff
all right so I need one weapon yes I
need equipment I'm not stalling for time
or anything
wait I thought I thought I got that for
Freddie okay maybe I didn't okay so now
we're Freddie upper okay all right then
I guess I didn't know god damn it get
out of there come on toto chica no
you're fine okay no there we go Optimus
okay so now he's relatively caught up
and I have pretty much what I need carry
on
so now what like I guess I'm just
farming the cameras I guess I just need
to kill the cameras let's start with
this one
engage the camera [__] I'm
pretty sure I'll be able to get this one
no problem Wow okay uh combat crash
right into that camera [__]
okay kids protection at put electroshock
into the thing and I guess you just do
whatever you wanted BAM
[__] I didn't do as much as I thought I
was gonna do well it's okay
that didn't go nearly top-hat crash lick
did nothing scream at that uh you do
that you also do that just in case okay
God I need better pizza oh Clark Bonnie
said Bam Bam Bam Bam you're not dead yet
oh [__] I'm I'm not no it's not gonna go
well is it I was not prepared
I was now prepared I need better pizza
Oh God not smoke no hey hey there we go
okay yeah just gotta finish them off
holy [__] okay there we go we're just
friends boppity-bop
there we go Wow dun dun dun dun Wow Wow
fourteen thousand holy [__]
alright so at least I learned better
skills now I Viking daddy eat my [__]
that was way too close like that should
have been way easier than it was okay so
what I probably need to do is I need to
I need to get better pizza for one
because I'm using way too many of these
things cuz I gotta be getting to the
point where I can have the pizza that
just refills all of the health at least
get it close to that also while I was
looking up the walkthrough I did
discover them the golden freddy that was
an extremely rare thing and it's also
extremely rare that it just kills me
outright so I was just extremely unlucky
right off the bat anyway
um this one I can really kill not you
your instant death blam
done and done okay I don't know if like
the Alpha streamers have like the
problem that the other ones did
problem uh you know what top hats and -
okay not only that probably don't need
that okay
blam-blam-blam-blam dun dun dun dun damn
damn damn damn not done but almost you
dancin there we go there we come back of
Aqaba flam dun dun okay I'm knockin
these cameras out like shame your
[__]
I don't know if that's an analogy that
works but hey I said it it's good okay
grab bag what the hell is grab bag do I
want to know what grab bag is do I
really want to know a grab bag is your
there like grab ass like rounds okay
yeah okay cool
so yeah this war here I'm gonna kick all
y'all's asses okay
yeah just mash it away this one's easy
okay this one's gonna be easy
hey goddamn critical in chica chicas
actually doing some damage now which is
a big difference from what she consumed
before which is absolutely dick deadly
finish off finish it off him off okay so
that's another camera down I'm doing
really good you're like really [__]
did it okay
so I had a skill that leveled up what
does that even mean boy Freddy had a
skill that leveled up is it just cuz I
used it enough that it leveled up or is
it just more than that there was
something else to it no idea okay be the
way doing good so far I need to find
where the other other Balloon Boy is
because I remember seeing something it
may have been in this one no it was in I
need to go to the puppet puppet buppa
buppa buppa buppa buppa god dammit get
out of my way I don't have time for you
I'm just annihilating you're barely
worth anything these days yes come on
please puppy puppy puppy puppy puppy not
that I don't want to fight the puppet I
mean eventually I'm going to fight the
puppet but just not god damn it get out
of my way you sons of [__] get out of
the way come on why isn't my wrists
cramping up no no a puppet man it's
illegal yup they don't know key now I
need to go back god you [__] just get
out of my way no one cares
come on come on come on back go up God
my wrist is cramping up like a son of a
[__] mashing the spacebar ow owie owie
okay
goddamn okay sir ah [__] get out of my
way these guys even think of try to go
up against me okay so it was over here
no I already got the Balloon Boy there
so where was the other [__] that's good
god damn it
uh-huh thank you I already got the old
abide over there anyway
okay so not there I guess I could take
up the camera there but I remember oh
that's where the last balloon boy is
okay I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to fight that one but might as well give
it a try you never know
hello you're just won against many of me
I'm gonna top hat smash the oh oh that's
the one that turned into level two okay
skills may cause paralysis grab-bag No
damn that was good actually yes hey
those easy goddamn those real easy
ok now blue boy finally yes ok cool now
I get the the best items I think I've
got a lot of tokens ok yeah that's good
ok yes yes yes yes ok
doing good ok hail my dog I know ok so I
need right now I need the guitar and the
hook those are the only ultimate items
that I don't have just yet optimise
demise demise it's really it still
throws me how much this is just like an
exact you know it's it's an RPG like
it's literally an RPG as Siddal as silly
as the wrapping is it's still just an
RPG ok ah so you do offer those I could
have gotten those before I thought that
was an exclusive thing to the special
surprise that I found still don't know
how to get the dragon dildo but hey it
is what it is okay there's got to be a
way I think it's good large pizzas it's
harder in this game to heal up than any
other one but I guess now that I got
more defence
I guess what I could do is I could farm
up more of the enemies in here try to
get the ultimate weapon for another dude
did I get it I think I got it [__] oh
whatever other screaming all your faces
you'll die anyway
I'll come on ah such son-of-a-bitch
come on here we go come on down in down
down down down it up
Go Go give me what I need give me what I
need baby give me what I need okay come
on lightning bolt learned ok nothing
else okay so either way I think I'm done
with this part I'm gonna farm up I'm
gonna farm up until I get the item that
I need here and level everyone else up
my hair it looks like I've got a hair
band thought it's very weird I don't
know what's going on with my hair right
now because it's very very desert like I
said in the picture that I took for
Instagram my hair reaches a point where
it looks good and then immediately after
that it looks terrible but do you like
fade you everybody so much for watching
check out the intakes for all the cool
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you
you are
how you go about you without move what